what i want to go over this in this
video is a special case of l'hopital's
l'hopital's rule and it's a more
constrained version of the general case
we've been looking at but it's still
very powerful and very applicable and
the reason why we're going to go over
this special case
is because it's proof is fairly
straightforward and will give you an
intuition for where why l'hopital's rule
works at all so the special case of
l'hopital's rule is a situation where
f of a is equal to zero
f prime of a exists
exists
g of a
g of a is equal to zero
g prime of a
exists if these constraints are met
then the limit
the limit as x approaches a
of f of x
f of x over
over g of x over g of x is going to be
equal to
f prime of a is going to be equal to f
prime of a
over g prime of a
over g prime of a so it's very similar
to the general case it's a little bit
more constrained we're assuming that f
prime of a exists we're not just taking
the limit now we're assuming f prime of
a and g prime of a actually exist but
notice if we substitute a right over
here we get zero over zero but then if
the derivatives exist we can just
evaluate the derivatives at a and then
we get the limit so this is very close
to the general case of l'hopital's rule
now let's actually prove it and to prove
it we're going to start with the right
hand and then show that if we use the
definition of derivatives we get the
left hand right over here so let me do
that
so i'll do it right over here so f prime
f prime of a
is equal to what by the definition of
derivatives well we could view that as
the limit
as x approaches a
of f of x
minus f of a
over
over x minus a so this is literally just
the slope between two points so like if
you have your function
f of x like this this is the point this
is the point a comma f of a
right over here this right over here is
the point x comma
f of x
this expression right over here is the
slope between these two points the
change in the change in our y value is f
of x minus f of a the change in our x
value is x minus a so this expression is
just the slope of this line and we're
just taking the let me actually do that
in a different color
this is the line that connects these two
points that's the slope of it i'll do
that in white
the slope of the line that connects
those two points and we're taking the
limit as x gets closer and closer and
closer to a so this is just another way
of writing the definition of the
derivative so that's fine let's do the
same thing for g prime of a so f prime
of a over g prime of a
is going to be this business which is in
orange f prime of a over g prime of a
which we can write as the limit
as x approaches a
of
g of x
minus g of a
over
x minus a well the numerator we're
taking the limit as x approaches a in
the denominator taking the limit as x
approaches a so we can just rewrite this
this we can rewrite as a limit
the limit as x approaches a of all this
business in orange f of x
minus f of a
over x minus a
over all the business all the business
in green
g of x
minus g of a
all of that over x minus a now to
simplify this we can multiply the
numerator and the denominator by x minus
a to get rid of these x minus a so let's
do that let's multiply by x minus a
x minus a over x minus a so in the
numerator x minus a and we're dividing
by x minus a those cancel out and then
these two cancel out and we're left with
this thing over here is equal to
the limit
as x approaches a
of in the numerator we have f of x
minus f of a
and in the denominator
in the denominator we have g of x
minus g of a
i think you see where this is going what
is f of a equal to well we assumed f of
a is equal to zero that's why we're
using l'hopital's rule to get from the
get-go f of a is equal to zero g of a is
equal to zero f of a is equal to zero g
of a is equal to zero and this
simplifies to the limit as x approaches
a
of f prime of x
f prime of x sorry of f of x we got to
be careful of f of x
over
g of x so we just showed that if f of a
equals zero g of a equals zero and these
two derivatives exist then the
derivatives evaluated a over each other
are going to be equal to the limit as x
approaches a of f of x over g of x or
the limit of as x approaches a of f of x
over g of x is going to be equal to f
prime of a over g prime of a so fairly
straightforward proof for the special
case the special case not the more
general case of l'hopital's rule